do you get offended when people play you
and don't do well like do you feel
misrepresented uh sometimes i guess
sometimes my son plays
and he just doesn't know how to use me
on the game so i'm like son what are you
doing but hopefully he'll get it soon
like make me win
he watches me enough i would think he
would know but
i'm recording if you can dunk the
following thing
a rake
a rake probably because i dunk a rate ah
the rates it wouldn't fit in the room
it'd be weird a horse's head
yeah probably a horse's head
maybe i could dunk that i feel like you
could
use lentils
loose lentils what's that
it's like a bean butter
but rice-like
do you ever do the girlfriend
yes i do do you ever like if you go out
of town do you ever like tell your
girlfriend to just like play you on the
game if she misses you does she ever
just like log on like just to see you on
there just to like move your little
avatar around and be like oh it's like
we're together in the living room just
like always except you're not on the
couch or in my tv i don't think she's
ever done that okay well not a bad idea
it's kind of a good idea
do you ever play as your nemesis just to
make them lose
play in the game i don't know i played a
win so i never try to lose i saw the
vine that steph curry posted of you
playing golf
and i also have a vine of me playing
golf i got a whole new one i got a hole
in one
was your swing as bad as mine it was
pretty bad well you know it's more of
like a tap
i'm wondering like
could you dump me like could you dug for
me like jamie no i couldn't do that
are you calling me fat
no i'm just not that strong maybe blake
griffin
you don't know who blake griffin is